put something mild infuriating on the
screen right now
ah don't like that all right we're
checking out the mile infuriating
subreddit
already it's so goddamn annoying being
here i don't
i don't know why i'm doing this to
myself but let's check it
out the way my girlfriend puts away the
groceries
still in the bag oh my god why did she
put
i thought it was a fridge is that a
fridge no
she's not that insane oh my god
you need a new girlfriend that's just
too far
and i think what's more annoying about
this is that you can't explain it to
anyone
hey why do you break up with your
girlfriend that you were perfect with
each other
well you see she wouldn't she just
wouldn't i don't know i tried to tell
her man
what did she do she wouldn't take the
grocery bags out of the grocery bag
groceries out of grocery bags
understandable see you sound crazy right
but it's totally justified
i feel your pain disney subscribe to our
streaming service for all our content
releases mulan
also disney money please for me
is for me wait wait a minute
are you saying one of the biggest
companies in the world
wants money
the dumbest thing i've ever heard
apparently my answer was wrong because
the teacher forgot to add an end
parenthesis
now that's not infuriating you got
played son you got played
get in the game you suck at math bro
cringe
also that equation is not solved the
[ __ ] was the question
hi is this available yes it is don't
need it
me neither wow we have so much in common
this is great oh my god this reminds me
when i try to sell stuff on ebay
people are so [ __ ] annoying on ebay i
wish there was a punch button
hi i know you said not to ask me
questions
but i still have a little question about
the item
buy they say this the reduced price is
buy it but
i want to know about can i have more
phones or something
shut up shut up
john it's so
annoying that's how i feel about that i
always put on ebay don't ask questions
i don't care you either buy it or you
don't i'm not trying to sell it to you i
mean i am but
[ __ ] someone set the toilet paper on
fire at my local kroger
i just [ __ ] up i don't know that's not
infuriating are you infuriated by that
i'm not should i be
why do i get so passionate about
something since i'm not receive a
notification from my robot app a roomba
requires your attention
run by stuck in here
no rumba no don't do it
well hot diggity damn okay
just bought this chair none of the
reviews mentioned this
yeah i i can sell you another chair that
doesn't have that problem although it
seems like an
acid get it i'm 30 now i make dad jokes
deal with it this one out of sync big
screen tv
oh god
the blinking this is funny you guys
don't understand
i'm getting mildly infuriated by the
fact that you guys don't understand what
mindly infuriating is
that's funny haha oh i have too many
emails in my inbox
why don't you send me an email about it
every day
it looks like you have too many emails
let's add some more
your inbox is full but somehow we can
fit a bit more
instagram influencers are renting sets
to pretend they take private jets
so that's not a private jet that's a set
why does it look like james charles what
the [ __ ]
like every software engineer has
experiences james
i can't escape them hey you studied
computer science right
yeah i need a favor this girl has
blocked me can you
hack into her phone and unblock my
number
i am a software engineer what the [ __ ]
do you think i do
you can't hack into the matrix then
what's the point of the degree
listen i'm sure this is annoying but i'm
not a software engineer i don't give a
[ __ ] come on oh it's my time
i'm getting annoyed what is this oh my
god is this photoshop because photoshop
does the exact same [ __ ] thing
here i'll show i'll show you something
annoying yeah you can photoshop
it's an amazing tool but it drives me
nuts dude all right so i have this image
right
cool sure and then i have another image
that's really small
okay happens i'm trying to grab the
image
but it keeps doing this so all right now
it works i swear to god every time i
don't
and now i'm getting annoyed the fact
that i can't even show it it's so god
god damn it
never mind people who call the meeting
for no reason at all just wanted to say
hi
lettuce yeah super annoying i feel that
all right i'm on board now
we're okay i'm looking at you pokey
my grade on an online quiz
did you ace the test son no i failed
with 0.0033
i'm ashamed of you son my god damn shade
slightly used
couch soft gray no pegs
hmm we're now the hmm somebody
i mean the pet is not on the sofa i'm
how i
married someone who does this
oh the context of that makes it so much
funnier that's awful
that's just i'm so sorry whoever married
this beast
jesus christ
[Laughter]
i got four tickets well looks like you
missed a big
base bonus come on french oh
that's annoying oh my god jesus
christ why is that so annoying this is
all
oh my god oh my god
something what i have no word
same same i mean they clearly built this
out so they could put the fireplace but
why on earth did they
oh
do as the teachers say not as the
teacher do
please use proper english come on guys
come in that's hilarious there's so much
wrong in this
isn't it oh you know what it sounds
annoying
my wrinkly ass t-shirt thanks a lot
jacksepticeye
[Laughter]
yeah when you hand someone a guitar that
doesn't really play and they grab them
by the
strings he's like
when you see it all right i haven't seen
it yet i always enjoy these
i still haven't seen it what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh i want to adjust that so badly please
can i
i'll fix it i'm fixing felix here come
on humanity was a mistake i've said this
so many times
do i need any more evidence than this i
don't think so
i don't know what bothers me more this
or how dirty that
chair is that's disgusting another
humongous one
oh i know what's gonna happen
[Music]
just wanted to see how everyone is doing
hello how is everyone doing just want to
make sure you're safe
need i say more oh my gosh yes
say no more i i'm actually worked up i'm
actually pissed off
oh yeah i forgot about these
it was so annoying they're like just
kind of
scott who designed these
designers need to be shot i said it
and i say it again bad design
ruins so much
i can't tell if i'm laughing at bullying
or something it it made me laugh i don't
know why
i'm i'm a bad person louisiana being o
and not the l what oh yeah
it could be level or
vel i'm not annoyed i'm not [ __ ]
reading that that annoys me that you
post think i'm gonna
oh my god what is wrong with people
holy sh oh
who did that come forward i wanna know
we need to find
i am i'm no i'm sick of this i'm sick of
just laughing it
we need to make some actual change from
now on all right
whoever did this step forward if you
know where this is
track them down we're not gonna hurt you
no one's gonna hurt you
we just want to talk ah
i'm in pain oh suffering
suffering to all humanity
what is that abomination
why would you do that why
[Music]
i swear to god i had this experience
when i was in japan and they stole the
alarm
they had this wall and they're like all
right we got to put the fire alarm thing
on it
and they just put in the dumbest place
most in
like i can't fathom why you would place
it there and i was just like
but can't you just place it there where
no one sees it
oh yeah of course
[Laughter]
this is the same remote for the led
lights yeah that's what you get for
being a cringy e girl with
led lights it's to prove that i'm a
gamer right you're not a gamer unless
you're rgb
350. oh my god yeah what a shitty
animation who did this
what the [ __ ] people who walk like this
blocking the entire parking lot
yep that is annoying vote pewdiepie all
right
trust me i'll get rid of these people
don't ask how i'll find a way
[Laughter]
someone tried to buy blocked nose spray
and amazon suggests
that they should buy beef tomatoes
instead hey who knows maybe works
will buy no spray imagine that happening
at a counter oh sorry we're at a nose
spray could we uh
could we introduce some beef tomatoes
perhaps instead
for your nose all right behold my lego
fall guy what's annoying about this
oh you never killed me i got g
fuel in my
oh my god yes spotify
ellen is not a genre of music
hey spotify i don't give a [ __ ]
about michelle obama all right stop
recommending me
michelle [ __ ] obama i'm not listening
to her podcast
look i go to podcast right every [ __ ]
time michelle
you want to zoom in i listen i'm not
hating on michelle obama
i'm not a hate michelle obama hater but
i don't know why
[Laughter]
i'm not are you don't forget i listen to
it
[Music]
hey everyone nah nah it's not happening
they even gave me a notification
it's out using every 10 pound
weight in the barbell area and music on
speakerphone
so we must all endure your favorite
music man oh so instead of
using the heavier weights they put all
of the 10 pounds
and the dumbbells too what the are you
doing i feel like there has to be so
much
gym etiquette that this is super
annoying i don't know what's more
annoying though because it's like you
could just ask her hey would you mind
switching these
or hey would you mind switching off your
phone i hate the whole
i'm just gonna take a photo of it and
post it on the internet that'll do
that's a beta [ __ ] you all know it i
find gyms are one of the most places for
selfish and entitled behavior i run
across
many people that think they own the gym
because they pay 30 bucks a month
yeah yeah unfortunately a lot of
douchebags but
a lot of good people too not everyone is
like this
no whoa is that real
holy [ __ ] uh how does that even happen
why does my shortcut for my calculator
look like that that's super annoying
what the hell
when the belt wouldn't quite reach the
next loop yeah that's very relatable
oh they missed a perfect opportunity for
a rhyme don't be selfish don't make us
ask thank you for wearing a face
covering
what the what is wrong with you the
worst part is when people wear the face
mask like this and they it doesn't cover
their nose and you're like
what the [ __ ] what's the point then
whatever your opinion on mask because
that which
apparently is an opinion now like
wearing it like that you just look like
a dumbass
plastic confetti left behind by a gender
reveal party in a public park
oh my god it's for people like these
that new laws are set in motion
that makes it so that no one can have
fun right that's how i see it
they're coming for fireworks next people
that don't clean up their fireworks or
some [ __ ] like that
oh we're gonna make it illegal now or
like people that don't
clean up their dogs and stuff like that
and therefore dogs aren't allowed in
certain areas it's like oh great thanks
you ruined it for everyone hate people
who try to get likes off of someone's
dad
yeah i i have another opinion on this
which is the base ascended opinion i
wish people would just ignore these
right i i think i feel like every time
someone uh passes away people start
arguing like oh i can't believe they did
this or oh look at what this person is
like
yeah just maybe just ignore that for now
i don't know
even though i agree with the sentiment
anyway how to find out how old is a tree
if you know when the tree was planted
you can easily
and accurately determine its age wow
google
thank you so much computers are so smart
i love it oh my god we have this in our
bathroom i'm not even joking
i brought it up to the construction
worker and they just looked at me like
great it's like hey look look what the
mistake you did
no response
the way my fiance loads the dishwasher
escape
run before it's too late
oh my god
[Laughter]
renters demand a new dryer since this
isn't working well
just the whole sweater dude what the
[ __ ]
it's broken i need a new one
oh my god uh if only there was a cheaper
natural right aesthetically pleasing
more all natural they said it to get the
shade if only
who makes these decisions it blows my
mind
i can't believe it and everyone else has
to just look at it
you know we need a way to hold people
accountable
right we need to track down who did this
no more
vote pewdiepie no more we'll have an
aesthetic department
i'm gonna assume that lid doesn't come
[Laughter]
on
[ __ ] i don't want i don't want to
drink anymore
[Laughter]
oh that's hilarious
a zoom feature that makes things smaller
wow how convenient
that's a probably an example of mild
infuriating i like that
i love this subreddit there's so many
emotions i don't know what to do with it
you never know what you're gonna get
would you mind holding a few minutes
while i'm checking this out for you no
worries
since i haven't heard back from you i'll
be stepping out of this chat
if you have any other questions please
feel free to contact us again
thank you for trading with abba trade
you said please wait
hello thank you
oh man crack me up man
can i look at that this was annoying
picture i've ever seen what is happening
what am i looking at
oh god the more i look the more confused
i get is it a scuba suit what is
it oh my god stop your brain is trying
to identify an object but it can't
i literally can't what what the [ __ ] is
this
the most annoying picture i've ever seen
[Laughter]
oh that's hilarious i was fine for
speeding when the car was in a tow truck
get played son oh my god
oh that's so annoying
don't they look at the pictures before
they send it out
oh my god jesus christ
how did how does that how does that even
oh god if i didn't touch it hey bro
would you mind typing this on my cube
god
the ants insist on taking dirt out of my
planter and dropping it on my deck
oh [ __ ] ants the goddamn ants
that's so annoying why are they doing
that
oh my god these for my
university term bill which is now
completely online and has
they charge you the same are you serious
are you [ __ ] kidding me like students
aren't getting ripped off
no problem g fuel uh special can doesn't
pull over
i mean whatever computer fee
this is very infuriating i wouldn't say
mildly furiating that's extremely
annoying
i've been reacting too much i i can't
stop play last one paid someone to power
wash the driveway
i did it boss i did the job nice and
clean bus
i like how they clearly started and just
gave up they're like
all right boss what an idiot if you're
mildly infuriated
there's a one cure smash like on this
video
subscribe we're trying to beat coco
yeah i don't know or coco melon bad has
this been infuriating is this annoying
is this distracting
are you annoyed right now well then i'll
got good news for you
new video tomorrow see you then bro fish
[Music]
ah